so um I said yesterday that I was going
to say a bit more about the Manifest
image and the scientific image because I
think especially on the topic of free
will it's very important to get clear
about what the difference is between
them and it both perfectly real let me
just remind you of a few things that are
in the Manifest image colors colors are
part of our manifest image unless we're
color blind living things and agents
opportunities there are opportunities in
the Manifest image that's one of the
things that we recognize Free Will
dollars there's dollars perfectly good
things scientific image has proteins and
atoms and quarks and maybe strings you
know we'll we'll get around to that and
so here's a whole bunch of different
things and they're obviously very
different opportunities in dollars are
not very much like atoms and
quarks um and they all as Steven was
saying yesterday they're all real in
some sense but maybe they are different
senses and the question of how to
negotiate back and forth between the two
images is the problem that
sellers uh recommends to philosophers
and I think he's right and I take myself
to be involved in helping people see how
to get back and forth between these two
images and Free Will is one of the most
important ones but um there's two
approaches let's go let's go back from
well no it's there's the hardnose
approach and the Diplomatic approach the
hardnose approach says from the
scientist X doesn't this it's just an
illusion doesn't exist colors don't
exist the alternative is well it exists
but it's quite different from what
tradition
supposes now look at a few
cases and decide for yourself how you
would go on these time does it exist it
does but it isn't quite what people
think it is right it may or may not be
but it certainly exists yeah
causation
doesn't how about color he's going to
give the answers coloror exist yeah even
though even though atams even though
Fons and bonss aren't color
does time exist in
time no all right how about dollars they
exist Euros yeah okay so it seems that
people here aren't very hard-nosed about
this they tend to take the opposite but
when it comes to Free Will well the Mad
Dog naturalist might take the hard well
indeed indeed but when it comes to Free
Will what I've discovered in the last
few years is there's a veritable Army a
veritable chorus of distinguished
neuroscientists and other science
that say take the hardnes approach to
this they say Free Will doesn't exist
it's an
illusion and I think they're making some
huge mistakes and I want to just outline
them
briefly well why do they think so well
let's look at look let's look at Dilbert
for a minute he's he's this is a this
epitomizes the Free Will issue you think
the chemistry the brain controls what
people do of course and how can we blame
people for their actions cuz people have
free will to do as they choose
are you saying that Free Will is not
part of the brain of course it is but
it's the part of the brain that's out
there just being kind of
free love the hand waving
there so you're saying the free will
power of the brain is exempt from the
natural laws of science phic obviously
otherwise we couldn't blame people for
anything they
do you think the Free Will part of the
brain is attached or does it just float
nearby shut up his tail is
lagging do shut up all right now I think
that actually captures the quandry of
the Free Will problem really very well
we have all the all the elements that
give people a problem and here's my
tentative diagnosis of what these
neuroscientists and others are doing
they they argue these ideas seem to be
incoherent they're right so Free Will
must be an
illusion and I want to show there's a
problem with this I think Free Will is
as real as colors and as real as
dollars but it's not quite what you
think they are any more than colors and
dollars are what you think they are so
in order to get clear about what free
will is you have to get abandon some of
the ancient
mythology which is indeed
incoherent here's here's Tom wolfa canny
Observer of the of the social scene
great phrase of his the conclusion
people out beyond the laboratory walls
are drawing is the fix is in we're all
hardwired that and don't blame me I'm
wir
drawing I think he's exactly right
that's the conclusion that is out beyond
the laboratory
walls but I want to challenge it and say
look oh I let I left out of slide I
guess wired wrong okay what would it be
to be wired
right um is there any way that you could
be wired right and have free will and
have
responsibility that's really what the
issue is and I'm going to claim that
nothing we've learned in Neuroscience
nothing we've learned in naturalism
shows that we can't be wired right for
free will but you have to understand
something a little bit different by uh
Free Will from what tradition would
say everybody knows how to play rock
paper and
scissors what's the best strategy there
is no mixed straty or no strategy
randomiz
randomize but we're lousy
randomizers so here's a good strategy if
you really were going to play this for
money go to a table of random numbers
copy down 100 memorize them or write
them down on a piece of paper consult
them go you can't do better than that as
long as you keep the piece of paper
secret
now this idea of
keeping your choices having a having a
poker face and keeping your choices
hidden is I think deeply appreciated and
is essential to the Manifest image but
what's happened is that philosophers for
several thousand of years thousand years
have thought it's not enough just to
sort of keep your choices hidden they've
got to be completely hidden they've got
to be hidden
absolutely so you want to be somewhat
unpredictable and this has been inflated
by philosophers for thousands of years
into absolute
unpredictability why because
philosophers always inflate to absolutes
when they can it just makes life easier
here's Jerry foder for instance one
wants to be what tradition has it that
Eve was when she bit the Apple perfectly
free to do otherwise so perfectly free
in fact that even God couldn't tell
which way she'd jumped perfect
expression of this inflated idea well
why does one want
that in other words one wants a
miracle you can't have it and you don't
need it all you need is to be
unpredictable to the agents that you
actually
encounter so let me let me sum up as a
sort of challenge if you think that
indeterminism is required for free will
I think you're wrong with one exception
and one exception
only if you anticipate a future in which
you think you are going to be playing
rock paper and scissors for big Stakes
with
God then you better hope for Quantum
indeterminacy to play a role otherwise
it doesn't matter a a deterministic
world is exactly as good as an
indeterministic world you're going to
have just as much free will in a
deterministic world as in an
undetermined world
as long as you keep your list to
yourself and you know the Le and Wang
experiments where monkeys play Rock
Paper Scissors against computers and
they monitor their brains the neurons in
the cital neurons so basically the
monkeys the monkeys Implement an
algorithm that gets as close to
randomization when the computer's
randomizing as a rcor Wagner condition
system can get which is not perfect
randomization yeah right it's it's it's
so the computer will gradually if they
play the monkey plays computer for a
long time the computer will suck it out
of money because it can't quite
randomize but it but it's it takes a
long long time it's basically as just
about as good as randomiz and that's the
neur that's the neural fire right we're
talking can I just ask because I think
I'm missing something extremely
essential here um what if I'm trying to
do something which I call make a choice
and nobody's in the room so how is
obscuring my thoughts from other agents
relevant to that it isn't relevant to
that at that time no it's but it's I'm
saying here's my here's my hypothesis
that human beings for thousands of years
have appreciated the value of a poker
face they have felt threatened whenever
they see somebody who seems to be able
to anticipate their decision- making if
you've ever had a magician force a card
on
you I I I hang around with card magician
someone a friend of mine once did
something he would never do in public
very good card magician he said here
pick a card any card and he
forced the the T of diamonds on me you
know or I picked the T of diamonds
handed it back to him shuffled the deck
just pick a card again T of diamonds
Shuffle the deck pick a card again the T
of diamonds he forced the T of diamonds
on me about 10 times in a row and I was
taking from the bottom of the deck I was
you know I was doing everything I could
think of and every time he anticipated
me exactly right it was extremely
unnerving I felt as if you know my
autonomy was really seriously abridged
and it
was I'd like to ask the mirror image
well before we start I have a counter
presentation which I was supposed to
give you I'd like to hear clarify if I
point just no but if I could hear Steve
point because I feel like I'm stuck at
the beginning I know you're going to get
to your C presentation yeah yeah I'll be
through in a couple of minutes oh s
sorry I thought you were I'm not quite
through no sorry well why don't I just
shut up why don't I just finish and then
you can all have at it all right here's
this here's this another one more slide
I'm pretty much through Free Will is an
illusion humans are nothing but moist
robots just relax and let it
happen all right moist robots I think
it's a great phrase that's what we are
we're moist robots uh that's what
cognitive find that's what naturalism
says now this is the this is the
conclusion that is out there as Tom Wolf
says in in in the zist this is what
people think follows from cognitive
science and from a materialistic view of
the mind and I think it's very important
that it doesn't follow it just does not
follow and that in fact uh scientists
who think it follows are committing a
very simple sort of freshman mistake
they are confusing the ideology of the
Manifest image with the Manifest
image the
fact Sean thinks color so do I but if we
let the Manifest if we let the ideology
of the Manifest image Define the word
color then we have to say oh well then
there's no colors if that's what you
mean by color colors don't exist if
that's what you mean by Consciousness
Consciousness doesn't exist if that's
what you
mean but we don't say that we say well
you know the the ideology of the
Manifest image is not accurate people
been making mistakes don't take it at
its face value and look at what the
Manifest image actually is and you see
that there is there are varieties of
free will that people recognize and deal
with every day they make distinctions on
the basis of it these are robust
concepts of free will that have zero to
do with
determinism and are perfectly consistent
with determinism they're compati so that
you can be a compatibilist uh uh in good
conscience what you have to give up
is the idea that the ideology of the
Manifest image rules as far as defining
the terms goes it
doesn't okay I think that's that's
it so what is the ideology of the
Manifest I give you an example how many
of you think you are qualified to sign a
contract of your own free
will notice there some people that
aren't there's a ly robust distinction
in the Manifest image between people who
have enough free will to sign a contract
and those that don't there's the the
scile and the impaired in various ways
small children they don't have the
competence to sign a contract but we do
now let's think about signing a contract
so you sign a contract of your own free
will and there's a if I don't there's a
penalty Clause of some sort and you and
you don't fulfill your side of the
bargain and the person comes back says
hey wait a minute uh you hav done your
side of theg you say well sue me guy
sues you you lose and you say collect if
you pursue this line eventually you're
going to go to
jail now when you go to jail it is not
for
rehabilitation it's not to keep you out
of the hands out of it's not to protect
the public from you it is punishment
it's
deterence well it yes but but it is it
is deterrence of those who have actually
violated the law and deterrence would
serve Justice well you weren't punished
but every sorry that everybody
what so my claim is that is there's a
there's a perfectly legitimate concept
of Free Will which is a somewhat
political
concept there we have for the for the
law we have to draw boundaries but we
don't make the mistake of thinking that
these are uh we're carving nature at the
joints there's no joint there in nature
you can 16 you can drive a car 15 and a
half you can't are you familiar with the
well-known paper by John RS the original
position political not
metaphysical yeah
that's what you're arguing I'm saying
that that Free Will is quite properly
seen
as falling right out of political facts
which are available in the Manifest
image none of us want to live without it
if you go around saying Free Will
doesn't exist Free Will is an illusion
you're actually undercutting the very
glue of
civilization and that's the reason that
people should be upset about it uh if
you don't believe believe that you
should learn about the experiments that
have been done I think the Vos and
schooler is the most
striking where undergraduates at Santa
Barbara read one of two passages from
Francis cric's book The astonishing
hypothesis one says science has shown we
don't have free will you you know every
decision you make is already determined
by your brain the other one same length
from the same book but it has says
nothing about free will then the
students are given uh an opportunity to
make money on a by by solving a puzzle
and it's pointed out to them that in
fact there's a way to cheat please don't
cheat be
[Music]
honest which group
cheats who read the the ones that were
just told by Francis Crick Nobel lauia
that they don't have free will they
cheat much more and this is not an
isolated result there are a lot of these
and it's not so surprising if you if
science authoritatively tells people
they don't have free
will people tend to believe that and
since they tend to believe that they
then don't think very hard about whether
they really ought to do things they
think you know I'm sort of off the hook
you know I'm a moist robot just sit back
and enjoy life and so people's
behavior degenerates into antisocial
Behavior as soon as they're convinced br
remember this is the answers to
questionnaire it's not the way they
behave it's where they well they do
cheat but it's not like in six months I
I challenge you to prove that those
people are more immoral than that are
more cheating than other people I mean
which was a short term effect well let
me are you through well I I I had my
other little thought experiment that I
thought I would run
through there is a a chip you can put in
your brain if you have OCD obsessive
compulsive disorder it'll it'll doip
brains yeah what you have a tendency to
put chips in brains yeah well that's
that's sort of my uh stock and trade
yeah but this is a real thing so far
science fact it it'll it'll really do a
good job on curing your uh
OCD preliminary you know it's pretty
good so you imagine some poor fell with
OCD goes in the neurosurgeon puts the
chip in his brain and then she says to
him oh yeah euros is good but by the way
from now on our 24/7 staff here at the
control center going to be controlling
your every decision every move you're
going to think you have free will but
that's just going to be an illusion
actually we're going to be making all
the decisions for you goodbye out he
goes and he believes
her and so his behavior he becomes sort
of self-indulgent he's not he becomes
negligent he lets his aggressions loose
in general he behaves badly and pretty
soon he gets caught gets put on trial he
said but I I don't have free will you
know the the neurosurgeon said you know
that I didn't have free will it was just
an illusion they call the neurosurgeon
put the neurosurgeon on the
stand and she says oh yeah that's I told
him yeah oh it's a complete lie I was
just messing with his head I just wanted
to see what would
happen I think we can agree she did a
very bad thing but he's still resp she
ruined
his life she disabled him she
accomplished non-surgically what she
claimed to accomplish
surgically she disabled him as a
responsible agent only because he didn't
know the nature of Free
Will right but now we have this chorus
of neuroscientists going around telling
science is shown you don't have free
will and I put it to them tell
me if that imaginary nurse surgeon is
doing something wrong something socially
irresponsible why isn't what you're
doing socially
irresponsible okay okay I'll give I mean
my answer what what you're saying
reminds me of the old saw that if people
fully accepted Evolution they're going
to ask like act like beasts that's what
creationists tell people the fact is
they don't act like Beast people that
accept evolution are just as nor as
other people so I mean you're you're
posing a danger which I demonstrate is
which I mean which I claim is only
empirically demonstrated in this course
a thing any let me let me let me let me
talk about what I want to say so okay so
I just I mean I was thought I was going
to go first I just had a refresher of
the three kinds of views of Free Will
dualism um nonphys non-physiological
libertarian Free Will which is basically
that the mind is independent of the
brain this is what Dan is saying was
dispelled a long time ago by everybody
um compatibilism that Free Will is
compatible with the idea of determinism
or laws of physics I think that's what
most of the people in this room are I
mean we all agree that the laws of
physics reign supreme so the question is
given that and the form of determinism
that that entails um do we still have
free will and then there's in Dan as an
advocate of compatibilism as we all saw
nobody in this room but a lot of people
in this Society are Advocates of um
non-physical libertarian Free Will and
finally incompatibilism which is my own
view that Free Will is not compatible
with the idea of determinism or the laws
of physics of course this depends on
what your definition of Free Will is
when you adjudicate between the last two
and I would maintain that compatible
lists have redefined Free Will from it's
traditional and Indigenous meaning in
society in a way to
either I mean I think Dan's motivation
might be the one to to keep people from
acting like beasts as far as I can see
um the only motivation pardon no no no I
know I know there's a long and
distinguished history of philosophers
saying that but I mean I didn't really
think that that was Dan motivation if I
read his arasmus paper which he makes
this pretty clear that we need to keep
this term free will but change its
meaning because otherwise Society will
fall apart I don't think we're changing
his meanion okay well I mean okay all I
can say is that I've you know my own
personal experience and questionnaires
there are conflicting results between
different scientific studies about
whether people are innately dualists or
not um the people I've talked to when
you tell them that their decisions have
already been made for them before they
make them are shocked I mean and when
you question them more deeply you
realize that people seem to indeed think
that they are agents and they can really
make decisions but that's just my
personal experience um so anyway I'm an
incompatible list I think that I retain
the definition of this is my definition
of free will you have to have a
definition of Free Will in order to be
able to see whether you're compatibilist
or incompatibilist my definition used to
be at which was similar what Sean was
talking about if you put yourself in the
same situation in the same universe with
every molecule in the same place Free
Will would mean that you have the opport
that if you come to a decision point you
could make more than one decision okay
but then I realized that Quantum
indeterminacy if it acts on the neuronal
level could make you make a different
decision under those circumstances and
it could even make you make a conscious
different decision if that somehow that
in that Quantum indeterminacy somehow
plays out in your Consciousness so I've
taken this definition from Anthony
casmore in his pnis paper the belief
that there is um something more than um
the consequences of your genes and your
environment um to your behavior um and
taking into account the possible
sarcastic sorry I say that's a strange
definition well all it is is it's it's
the physicalist or materialist
definition of okay well I mean you can
contest this these are this is meant to
be provocative okay and I I also have to
say that I freely admit that I'm not a
philosopher and I've been accused of
philosoph opical naivity and there's
some truth in this and also what I say
about incompatibilism here is not
necessarily aimed at the incompatible
sorry at the compatible lists in this
room it's just sort of my take on the
whole Viewpoint so first of all let me
let me talk about what I think we all in
this room agree on I think Dan's talk
reinforced this that there is no dualism
there's no ghost in the machine the mind
is the equivalent to the brain second of
all we don't have Coan Free Will in the
sense that I say um we we can only make
one decision at one time I really think
that's true I I others argue about
whether Quantum indeterminacy can affect
our Behavior I as far as I can see it
doesn't at least from you know making
decisions um so we have to Define Free
Will differently to get comparism um we
can make no decisions other than the
ones we do at a given moment unless
Quant in determinacy affects the
decision process if it doesn't then I
think we would all agree if we choose
between vanilla or chocolate ice cream
at any point that decision has already
been made for us before it reaches our
Consciousness jary I think you maybe to
Short Circuit things a little bit you
could deal with this qu Quantum
indeterminacy issue just by saying that
there is an objective prediction about
what you will do next given by the
factors you mentioned it may be deter
100% or it may be probabilistic but it's
objective based on your atoms yeah and
that's what cash want I you said we all
agree I don't agree with your last
statement about chocolate and vanill ice
cream I don't think that even on a
completely non-dualistic point of view
that we uh are that our that the
decision is made that we will have
chocolate or vanilla uh before we
consciously decide that okay well
there's some
neuroscientific experiments I mean some
people take issue with these about that
you can predict which button you're
going to press with a certain degree of
accuracy before you consciously decide
which Buton we can discuss those experim
but they're very in a very limited
context anyway okay well anyway given
the laws of physics I I claim that this
is almost an aior truth and finally um
we're prcts of our genes in our
environment some late okay my problem
with compatibilism is best expressed by
Sam Harris I mean in some sense I agree
with Dan that we have a manifest image
of free will but I think it's it's
crucial to recognize the reality um for
other reasons I mean Dan wants to keep
the Manifest image because he thinks
Society will fall apart if we don't
accept that I think that there are
pernicious consequences of of not
recognizing determinism in terms of our
decisions and and one well my problem is
is about you know what's really going on
people feel that they are the authors of
their decisions and this is the only
reason why there's a problem of Free
Will worth talking about that is are we
really the authors of our decisions Dan
says no we're not but it doesn't matter
okay I say no I say we are the authors
of our decision well but we're perfectly
material things we're we're moist robots
who are the authors of our decisions
well in the same sense that a computer
is an author of its decis well but we
have to look closely at what kind of
computer it is okay I'm almost done can
you say more about that yeah all right
sorry um so I think there's a certain
number of um similarities between
sophisticated theology which is this is
deliberately might to be provocative and
not to really be insulting but there are
some similarities between theologians
who don't recognize the truth of the
Bible but nevertheless tell it to their
flock in order to keep them compliant um
and compatibilism the first one is um
that both Define the old Notions in the
case of theologians biblical literalism
in the case of compatible Free Will and
then claim that nobody really believes
these anymore there are plenty of
compatibilists who say nobody's really a
dualist okay second of all both set
humans deight as special many compatible
and I'm not sure the ones in this room
say that only humans have free will and
animals don't computers don't Etc so
we're set aside in that
respect um and in both cases academic
Doan said sometimes say that it's
dangerous for the public to know the
truth um either about you know the fact
that our decisions are determined by our
environments or our genes or that you
know maybe God exists as a ground of
being rather than as an actual sky
father out there okay um should we hide
from the public um this is from Dan's
arasmus paper where he says explicitly
that um if neuros science are saying
that it is no use we are already puppets
controll by the environments they're
making a big and potentially harmful
mistake but I think it's true that we
are puppets I mean we are the puppets of
our genes and our environment and they
completely determine what decision we
make
so um there's another quote below that
it's likely to have which Dan just said
profoundly unfortunate social
consequences um
and another quote which Dan made on the
point of inquiry podcast in 2011 we
don't want people disabling themselves
with bad science um I think this is a
very serious issue I'm not sure that
saying that determinism Reigns or the
law of physics Reign is bad science and
when I see a quote like this it reminds
me of something that Alex said yesterday
um my dear descender from the eights let
let us hope it's not true but if it is
so let us hope it not it does not become
generally known I let's keep keep the
public unaware of determinism okay um we
don't really need to know this is
yeah is it time to I'm almost done okay
this is my next to last slide I'll tell
you when it's done okay this is a
comment on moment a reader blog what
we're up against human will is not free
but we must say we must not say it is so
um uh so two more slides actually why
can why I think that it is important to
concentrate on more than just the
Manifest image in the case of Free Will
first of all and Sean's going to object
to this but Dan I think might not
because he says we need to be
politically aware of the uses of our
language that if you say we have free
will it somewhat enables religion by
making it theists think that the form of
Free Will is proposed by compatibilist
is the same as their form of Free Will
which is truly dualistic that is you can
choose whether or not to accept Jesus it
misses a critical issue the absence of
dualism and the hedge money of
determinism and materialism I the brain
is the mind I think this is a very
important message which we need to get
out to the general
public and yet people who are
compatibilists tend to neglect this and
say well that yeah this is the truth but
you know we have free will in this other
sense and it's to me it's much more
important that the public realize this
than that they have a conception of free
will that comports with determinism um
for a number of reasons um I think it
that last thing again you say they have
a conception of free will that comports
with sorry
said it's more important that people
believe that the mind is the brain than
that they have a conceptual free willfor
with determinism yeah
um uh I think it takes it may have the
danger of taking the science out of the
question of free will I mean people tend
to dismiss the LI experiments and the
sooner all experiments on grounds other
no more substantial as far as I can see
them that they don't like the results oh
no those are those are I believe me I
will take those experiments all right
all right well I mean this is meant to
be provocative gender discuss um I think
it sidesteps the questions of morality
and moral responsibility are there if we
are truly deterministic in our decisions
is the concept of morality and moral
responsibility have any meaning at all I
mean maybe the concept of responsibility
does but not moral responsib and I think
the most important reason why we have to
keep our eye on the true reality rather
than the Manifest imagees because I
think it has different consequences for
Retribution and Punishment I mean
whether or not you punish an 11-year-old
for beating his little sister to death
depends on what you think whether you
think you know what motivated that
behavior or not and did that person
behave freely or not well don't talk
about an 11year old talk about well
anybody anybody anybody I mean I think
that your view of that the view your
view of river I'm I'm a philosophical
tyo here okay so I'm not going to
pretend to know all the nuances but I
think compartible is free will
completely neglects the question unless
you start taking off well will is really
determined by our Jes of environment
neglects the very important question of
how we're going to reform the judicial
system of rewards and punishments based
on what we know about Neuroscience okay
that and my Modest Proposal is that we
get rid of the notion of free will
completely and replace it by this
statement um which is from Marvin Minsky
my decision was caused by internal
forces I do not understand and then the
really interesting questions to me which
aren't about about questions of
competitiv Inc comparism what are the
effects of determinism on view of
punishment and reward philosophy and
jurist Prudence there's moral
responsibility mean anything beyond
responsibility IE you did it you have to
go to jail because you're the person
that did it not because you were wrong
and you or you had a choice how far
ahead can we predict decisions before
they're made consciously um the Ambit of
um responsibility as science philosophy
Juris
Prudence um what are the factors that
affect our decisions and how do they
play out in the brain that's the
scientific question and finally which is
a very interesting one um we have a
feeling of agency that as we can
actually make our brains make a choice
which which we can't really um is that
feeling of agency a product of natural
selection why do we feel that we are
agents that have free choices is that an
epiphenomenon is that a spandrel or is
it something that has been installed in
our brain by natural selection because
as some scientists think the feeling of
agency is an adapt
one and oh and then I had a list of
questions to hand out to ponder which I
forgot but I think we have plenty of
questions to ponder already so so that's
it Dan it might have be us helpful for
you this little fact the most common
excuse in South Africa among murderers
caught red-handed is my ancestors did
it uh I I wanted to respond to both uh
talks I'm very much on uh
Dan's side although in one respect I
disagree with him too uh I think that
any action is the result of a chain of
causation any action a person takes is
result of a chain of causation very
often that chain includes conscious
decisions um my my coming here is a
result of a conscious decision in which
I weighed my desire to see you all and
to see my family in Lennox and uh I I
went through weighing that against the
trouble of air travel on American
Airlines and uh came to a decision I
know as surely as I know anything as
surely as deart knew that he existed
that my Consciousness was involved in
that decision now excuse me how did you
know that by introspection Yeah by
experiencing the Consciousness the same
way I know I exist
um now I don't know why I wanted to see
my granddaughter so much I don't really
know um in detail why I have certain
intellectual interests that led me to
want to come here uh I can trace it back
a little bit but eventually I get to a
level where I don't know why I wanted to
do what I consciously decided to do and
so it's possible that everything was
completely
deterministic uh and yet I part of the
chain the deterministic chain was a
conscious decision except that that now
if they put electrode in your brain and
told you before you made your conscious
decision that you were going to come
here would that change your
mind that your conscious decision had no
role on that well I don't know whether
the electrode would actually change my
Consciousness I don't you're not denying
the correspondence between your decision
and your brain state so that's not yeah
that's right of course it's my bra I'm
denying that well let's get back to that
the uh and and that chain of causation
may involve indeterminacy and here I
agree with Dan that it isn't really
important whether the quantum effects
introduce a determinacy indeterminacy or
not but I I would go I now the question
well let me come back to that the
question is is this a good definition of
of Free Will namely that I had the
conscious of experience of deciding I
think it's a good definition a free will
because it's what I care about free
about
it I consciously decided to come here
that's what's free that's my definition
of Free Will why do I want to Define
free will this way because it's what I
care about introspective access to the
fact that he could have made the
conscious decision not to come he knew
at the point that he made that decision
from the inside that it was up to him
the whole history of the world being
what it was until that moment he could
but still he could well I wouldn't quite
I wouldn't quite say that I would say
that no given my I was hoping no given
given my uh my background with my my
hormones which make me want to see my
granddaughter it may very well be I had
no choice but I made the choice and that
is
um the eye who was conditioned by those
hormones then as a result of that
condition decided to come here and I so
I had the conscious experience of making
that decision but that's not the same as
you having made the I mean that your
brain having decision well but that's
what I care about because that conscious
experience of making a decision is the
kind of free will that seems to me to
matter yeah let me let me let me support
what Stephen is saying with I'm going to
give but I don't I want to disagree with
you about okay all right but I think I
have a different way of putting what I
think Stephen is St I'm going to give
you four decisions every one of them is
caused by the combination of your
hormones and your history and your genes
and the environment this is the one in
your residents paper you're going to say
yeah about Corn Flakes yeah right I
already know that all right but but the
but the other stuff all right because
but but I have a question for you that I
didn't raise in in that
so case one my doctor tells me I should
eat brand blobs because they're good and
healthy for me and I need to keep my
cholesterol down I trust him I agree
with him and so I go out and buy some
brand Blobs of my own free will as we
say whatever it means case number
two I just go to the store I read it on
the box it's highlighted in yellow I
trust the Kellogg Company I decide
they're probably telling the truth so I
buy the brand
lobs case number three I go into the
store and there's a box of brand blobs
with this fetching picture of Cameron
Diaz on it and I buy the box of R Bobs
bad
taste four I go into the store and
there's a microchip hidden in the box of
cornflakes which tickles my nucleus
accumbent and I buy the box of brand
blops in every case the environment has
caused me to make a choice intuitively
they are profoundly different choices
the first two at least are free choices
because although the environment is
causing me they're causing me to use my
rational
evaluation and to think about what
matters to me and what more I want the
world to cause me to to make decisions
like that so those are just fine the
third case if I were a a really naive
person we could begin to say ah the
Puppeteer is working on you I'm not a
naive person I know about that so if I
buy it because Cameron Diaz is on the
boxes I'm rewarding the Kelloggs company
for their good taste in women
again it's free it's only the fourth
case where I'm being manipulated by
another agent and I don't know it
there's a puppeteer and Sam Harris puts
those puppet strings on the cover of his
book and that strikes me
as sort of intellectually dishonest
actually except that I sort of agree
with them and and I know you just said
you did in your case if you respond I'd
say that there is no substantive
difference between those four
Alternatives I mean that's what I wanted
to you think there's no more free will
in the first two cases than the
absolutely yeah because you're you're
still being manipulated by various
factors it's just it's you're using
different you had a brain T before okay
s especially to Steve's counter to to uh
Dan um the role of conscious experience
uh you mentioned liit and so did you uh
and I think we can all agree that liet's
experiments do not
establish the um the denial of free will
but what they do seem to me establish
and I'm interested in being educated if
I'm mistaken is that we cannot trust
conscious experience as a guide to what
is happening in
our uh uh lean's Bel uh we can't trust
conscious experience to tell us what the
causes of our actions are including when
it tells us that conscious willings are
the causes of our action
and that along with a lot of other
evidence undermines the role of
conscious experience as an epistemic
guide to a lot of stuff but you agree
with that Dan I I agree with that except
I think you're putting more emphasis on
the last conclusion that you draw from I
agree that our conscious experience our
introspective judgments are not they're
not conclusive they're not privileged
but they are they are EV they're
evidential they are evid and and the r
experiments don't undermine them
not absolutely not the livid experiments
are are misconceived from the ground up
so and all the replications successful
applications they are also misconceived
from the ground I'm sorry not only
they're misconceived uh I think as you
guys have pointed out actually uh some
of conceptually but there is a paper
that just came out this year that has
repeated those experiments and actually
has come to completely different
conclusions not didn't really repeat
that they did tring one where they did
not where they just looked at action
potential
so who wants to want to be you better
not ask me to do it because I've refuted
these so many times that I can't do a
fair job Dan and I thought we got these
off the face of the universe in by
1990 it's an well but I can tell you
what it is okay so yeah go ahead what
liit does is he pays uh undergraduates
uh money to come in and their job is to
flex their hand when the urge comes
comes upon
them the motor cortex is being uh
monitored and they're looking at a clock
uh and uh what happens is that they're
supposed to tell you when they have the
conscious urge to flex their hand and
allegedly uh the um action the uh uh the
action potential the the um Readiness
potential in motor cortex starts to show
itself active t 50 milliseconds before
the conscious urge to flex occurs John
Dylan Haynes has now says he can he can
see activity that's building up before
people make choices to look at the left
corner or the right corner of the room
antecedent to conscious intentions uh I
could comment on my view of these but
it's similar to understand what it's
supposed to show is that the entire
causal pathway that is sufficient in the
circumstances for the hand flexing or
the button pushing or the eye movement
has begun
significantly before the felt Act of
willing but how do they know when the
felt Act of willing
is the Observer says that's when I yeah
init original experiments there was a
large clock with a slow secondhand
sweeping and you're supposed to tell
when where that was we talk about a
quarter of a second right and I mean for
a person to to say now
takes more than a quarter of a second
well notice in these experiments among
many many other problems the the people
have accepted money in and consciously
loaded up in intention to comply with
the
experiment so it's a disaster at many
different levels but I mean whoever
expected unless you're a dualist for
nothing to be going on in the Brain
before conscious decision making or
hormones not only that but it's it's the
predictability not just the fact that
you can tell when something's going to
happen but you can predict whether
you're going to use your right or your
left hand but notice notice that in all
of these
experiments they choose as their model
Choice a an act grat a completely
unmotivated it's a whim it's and they
rule out the case if you decide in
advance I'm going to decide when X or
when y but now treating that as our
model free choice is in itself bizarre
bizarre naive it's just well but but no
it isn't because because first of all
back to my rock paper and scissors you
want to you want to you want to act
randomly rock paper is a pretty good
model of the same thing right but how do
you do that well you got to make
something happen in your brain that you
yourself don't have any access to so
that you don't have a poker face and
then boom you do one so in
fact ideally if you know
if if panglossian God were to design you
as a free agent to play rock paper and
scissors the soon effects would show up
in your brain because you'd want them to
show up you wouldn't want to be able to
see the effects churning away in your
brain eight or 10 seconds in advance
that was going to determine your choice
because then you'd give it away with
your
Pokerface so what subjects are doing in
those experiments is doing something
they have no idea what they're doing
they're sitting there going I don't know
and somehow or other they manage to
provoke something to happen in their
brain which over a course of actually
seconds well they don't provoke it's
something
else of course the experimental the the
the experimental situation puts them in
a condition where they something happens
in their brain which they can't report
and which is some predictive there's
some real problems with some of the
predictiveness first of all notice that
they're not actually predictive they're
predictive in the scientific sense but
it takes you know hours of computation
to to get the predictions out I used to
say as a sort of joke the big moral of
the soon experiment is don't play rock
paper and scissors from money with soon
with your head in an fmri
machine but in fact go right ahead
because it's going to take him an hour
or two to analyze the data so remember
everything is Crew That's not I mean Dan
you I mean presumably you're you would
disagree with Stephen and that at the
point he made his decision to come here
you would say that decision was already
predictable from first principles before
he actually was consciously aware of Mak
having made that decision well well I
think that doesn't matter well no I'm
asking you yes or no think you're you're
misstating what what I was saying
actually I'll tell you why
not
there's a conditional prediction that
I'm sure you could have made and you
probably you could have gotten Rich
betting on it namely that he would put
all the factors that matter to him in
the hopper and he would say yeah I'm
going to go but of course if he listens
to the radio 10 minutes before he
decides and he hears about some crucial
thing happening then he isn't going to
go so all bets are off so when did he
actually decide he decided when he
decided and even though look suppose
that there were political scientists who
could study
Congress and two weeks in advance they
could predict how Congress was going to
vote on a
bill and suppose they were accurate h no
yeah when when did Congress decide that
gets back to the question when they
voted is real you know they decided when
they voted the fact that the decision
was predict they voted wrong okay so so
Steve listens to the radio and he says
the weather's bad he's not going to go
10 minutes for all I admit that's an
environmental input but
still If he if that decision is 100%
predictable before he consciously says
okay I'm going to go I would claim that
you will claim what that that his notion
of Free Will is not is the wrong one can
I just ask about the notion of free will
just to see if we can just expand this a
little bit I mean I think Dan you said
that you have a compatible notion of
free will and I'm going to try to read
my notes here but you said one that is
very different from what tradition
supposes yeah okay I quite I quite agree
that that there is a tradition which
thinks that Free Will is incompatible
the one that Jerry put up on the board I
think you're happy to discard but you
want a notion of free will that that I
think both you and Stephen say one
should want that's valuable but it's
very different from the way we
traditionally view it and so what I what
I want to get because I'd be excited to
have my you know impression of this
change is what is that definition
because I still haven't quite well for
me it's the heard it it's the cons it's
the fact that a conscious decision
process was part of the chain of
causation only a part yeah it's not it's
not at the bottom of the chain it's not
the first step in the chain it's a link
in the chain of causation that leads to
the action tell I got a two I got a two-
word definition which if you if you
don't get it I can spell it out to any
length you want moral
competence okay can I can I Riff on that
because Hillary boach isn't here and I
don't know her personally but I did read
one of her writings on this so can I
read her definition I think she makes
one but I haven't completely understood
it so I want to read it and see if
people can help me she says um a person
whose actions depend on her choices has
Alternatives if she is in addition
capable of stepping back from her
existing motivation and habits and
making a reason decision among them then
according to compatibilists she is free
is that pretty close I have I'd have to
think very carefully whether I want to
add I I think I probably want to add a
few things me it might be useful if I I
think it would help fix because I I
understand why Jerry and Dan have this
there's this tension um let me just tell
you about some experiments that have
been done because this has to do with
what the concept of Free Will means I
mean uh
so a a philosopher named Eddie namas he
does he was a student of mine actually
and this comes out of his dissertation
he was interested in what do Ordinary
People mean by Free Will and he did
these experiments which are very simple
to describe he gives uh you
undergraduates at Florida State and then
Georgia uh State uh scenarios where
there's a laosan demon actually and it
says that um Mary Jones uh will be born
uh in 2000 and in 2034 she'll Rob the
lead County Bank at such and such time
in downtown Stockbridge of uh
$50,000 and then the undergraduates are
asked questions like this Berkshire
count did she uh did she uh do it on
purpose uh did uh uh is she responsible
for
it um uh did she do it intentionally and
and uh and questions like uh did she uh
is she resp responsible for it and so on
and so forth then they end questions
like is it determined that she will do
it could you have predicted that she
would do it and they find that he finds
that 87% of American college students
are compatibles they think you can
disassociate complete predictability and
complete determinism from having she did
make a conscious choice on that day she
wakes up that morning with her plan to
go rob the bank and that was these
students think that's sufficient for
saying she did it intentionally she did
it responsibly and so on now notice the
concept of Free Will is they're trying
he's trying to pull out the concept of
Free Will and not make it play any role
because it is so contested but showing
that you get certain even in a
deterministic and predict fully
predictable world there's another paper
that came out subsequently which claims
that paper is flawed and uses other
questions I can't adjudicate between
them but says that America that the
students they surveyed are incompatible
that's I should have brought that paper
cuz I have a big F SE n paper I can't
okay I can't remember but I mean what
she get depends on he that's the
question question so I wouldn't use that
they're just students anyway but Sur but
surely we have to admit that religious
people in general question to both Jerry
and and and and actually over and over
here so it seems to me that in unless I
misunderstand some of these positions
that somehow uh the fact that the brain
uh is evolved to make decisions to uh to
reflect on things get inputs and then
produce a particular output seems to be
somehow bracketed out of this discussion
why isn't that a cause that is not by
you but by incompatible that is why
isn't that the brain's ability to make
to reflect and to think about things
isn't also that part of the mechanism
and therefore in an important sense my
decision to come here is my decision
because it was made by my brain which
yes it is the result in without doubt of
a complex series of Gene environment
interactions throughout my life but it's
also a a a a biological machine if you
want to use that analogy I don't
particular like it but a biolog there is
a distinction because your brain may
make you your heartbeat you're you
breathe uh it may produce reflexes when
your knee is hit that doesn't involve
conscious conscious choice and I don't
call that free will even though it's
your brain so what's so special about
Consciousness what what's so special
about cons well that it's that it's part
of the decision making process we don't
know that Consciousness could follow the
decision
let's try what else is there here's
another distinction that is not and and
and by the way I'm don't propose this
distinction as the distinction on the
basis of which we'll get the free
choices on one side and the other on
because I don't think there's any such
principle but but admitting blurry
boundaries uh it is an important
distinction I think when thinking about
what matters about Free Will
so I make a some some decisions I make I
make by
uh especially social decisions or
decisions that have some sort of
normative significance I make them
partly by asking myself thinking about
what sort of person is it I I I I I want
to be what sort of action would be
consistent with that sort of person so
there there the decision is then very
much a product of my own sort of
narrated
self right and um now that's seems to me
to implicate My Free Will in a much more
profound way
than uh than to thought you know than
than something else that I you know when
I when I
accidentally uh drive home while having
intended to go to the gym right because
I'm not thinking about it very different
they're both decisions in some sense
they were both done by my brain there
was nothing no no brain other but but um
from the point of view of what matters
about free will they're very very
different kinds of decisions course you
can input output from it's just that in
one case the inputs are a lot more
complicated no but in one case it was I
it was in one case it was my conception
of
myself my normatively weighted
conception of myself was clearly part of
the causal story that explains why I
made that decision other case it wasn't
that's what you think but but I would
contend that not true maybe I would say
what the point of VI Jerry is advocating
is sort of solved by the move that Terry
made this morning which is to say we
should remember what we said yesterday
okay you keep all that straight so in
other words if we remember the emergence
discussion and we the extent to which we
bought into it there's different levels
or
vocabularies uh that describe different
parts of experience and they can
describe them in very different ways and
my favorite example is you know the
atoms and the thermodynamics of the air
in this room and they're so different
that features that are absolutely
Central to the microscopic description
might be utterly absent in the
macroscopic description so at the
microscopic level of atoms we have time
reversal invariance right everything
happens equally uh well forward and
backward in time and at the macroscopic
level we have the second law of
Thermodynamics where there's this
dramatic difference and I would say that
Free Will is to neurons or atoms as uh
Second Law is to the atomic theory of
gas it's something that seems
incompatible because you're using the
wrong vocabulary to talk about and I
think that your argument against free
will if I followed it step by step would
say there can't be any such thing as the
second law of Thermodynamics because the
atomic physics is completely time
symmetric you're saying there can't be
any such thing as free will because down
at the level of neurons everything is
just deterministic and I could imagine
what it is and my response would be you
can either speak the language of people
and their interactions and their
conscious reflection and making choices
in which case Free Will is a useful
concept or you can speak the language of
neurons and action potentials and things
like that in which case everything is
deterministic and those two things are
completely simultaneously compatible and
I think that you know the the it would
be it sound it seems paradoxical because
you say how can I possibly have free
will when my neurons were going to do
this paradoxical because you're using
the same word twice you're using you're
using you're speaking different
languages in the same sentence and I
think that's where it goes from but you
agree that there are profound
differences in for human so I mean Dan
say if we are incompatible if Society
falls apart I would claim that okay
that's a great thing to talk about that
I I want to say has nothing to do with
what I just said I mean I I you knowe
okay that is interesting to talk about
but let but let's just be purely you
know good Scholars and say how should we
best describe the world um and so so my
reasons for being a compatibilist are
purely that like I said said at the very
uh introductory SE section right now my
best theory of human beings at the level
of human beings includes Free Will and
as an empiricist if there's some is a
better theory of human beings out there
that does not require that uh I can't
imagine what it would be because you
know I can't imagine speaking a language
of human beings that doesn't let me make
choices but you know I would be happy to
get rid of that okay so what is your
definition of Free Will and then explain
what is free about it so let me let me
actually let me I will answer that but
let me say something that you just
reminded me I wanted to say um in
exactly the same way that Dan is
pointing out that what we mean by free
will even though it's a very useful
concept might be different than what we
used to mean by it traditionally I would
say the second law of Thermodynamics
became different when boltzman explained
to us that it all comes from atams the
second law preceded atomic theory right
and it was thought to be a true tendency
of matter yeah but it was false it
turned out that the second La
phenomenological Second Law is false it
has a domain of applicability which is
very very very wide and but but but but
more importantly it's I mean there's a
reason why we still call it the second
law we didn't invent a different term uh
but more importantly its ontological
status changed and we nevertheless kept
the terminology it used to be a true
autonomous feature of matter that it
wanted to go from lower to higher
entropy and boltzman came along and said
no no no there is no such tendency
everything is reversible it's all just
atoms but in this particular kind of
setup which happens to be our universe
in which we live the second law is still
an extremely Central way of thinking
about reality so I'm happy to change
that definition in that kind of way so I
would so the definition I would give is
just pretty close to I think what
everyone is trying to give from Steve's
uh uh comments onward you know it's the
fact that so if I want to say will I
pick up this glass okay now you might
say well deep in my neurons and in the
environment of the world there there's
an answer that lus demon could compute
which is fine but I will also say if I
decide to pick up the glass nothing's
going to stop me if I decide not to
nothing's going to force me that's my
free will ask I am very interested in
what Steve wants to say in response to
uh uh Dan but just to ask whether I have
a grip on your view is it a fair gloss
on your view to say Free Will is part of
a system of Institutions for social
control that is important for the
Persistence of
society
yes it's part of the Manifest image and
the Manifest image for human beings
unlike the Manifest image for say
porposes or ticks or ter and if but if
is includes culture and society and so
our understanding of Free Will is in
part a cultural artifact in
part well first of all free will is in
part or in whole a cultural artifact you
also think it's part of the best
description we can think of right yeah
that
is deeply embedded in our Behavior I'm
going to try to speak very carefully and
not load this if you look at human
behavior if you Anthropologist from Mars
you come here and you look at our
Behavior one of the concepts that you
are going to impute to
us is Free
Will and you're going to impute it to us
on the basis of the role it plays the
distinctions we make who we punish who
we don't who we exonerate who we trust
who we're prepared to make a promise
with
and so forth we take that if you take
all of those facts we and that exhausts
and
once it exhausts
it given that we're not just doing
anthropology we're also going to do
neuroscience and biology and we're going
to see that that man manifold of social
behaviors are also of course have an
evolutionary history they they are
sitting on top of evolutionary
competences and what we're going to see
is that human brains have competences
that other brains just don't have so
that's my question is there any reason
by the way wait a minute my question we'
we we're in this human domain right okay
so do we have more free will than my dog
yes than my bird yes so what does it
mean actually actually I think I think
that Sean put his finger on it uh
indirectly
we and only we have have two features
that your dog and your bird don't
have we have imaginations that can see
much farther into the future and value
and and disvalue those Futures so we
have sort of a moral imagination about
the outcomes of our
acts and we are movable by reasons that
is by the representations of reasons we
can be talked into things and talked out
of things the way my doctor talked me
into buying brand blobs that's why when
I buy a box of brand
blobs I'm acting with free will if my
dog eats brand
blobs it's not it's it has no
significance in other words in other
words we have a much more sophisticated
decision making organ here than than the
dog degree it's not a difference in time
it's a difference in degree it's a
different it says it's a difference in
degree sure so at some point evolution
of I want to Saye
will we didn't in fact in fact not only
that but in individual human cases we
aren't born with free will we grow into
free will we become responsible adults
but now it's the problem the word free
aren't we talking about um we have you
might say in a Shannon sense there's a
higher entropy and a lower bias on that
entropy for our choices that's what
you're really saying not that it's the
the term free is it gets us in trouble
well there's there's one way one one
place where I definitely do agree with
with Jerry which is we should really
agree to get rid of talk of free will
now ctive scientists and psychologists
have a better term for that they use the
term volition the ability of making
decisions it's not you know and reflect
about those decisions yes if you start
if you put the word free there that
automatically makes people think about
Contra causal stuff and it comes out of
floats out of nowhere the cartoon no
none of us wants that right no none of
us is actually into that so let's get
rid of that if you don't like valtion
I'm I'm perfectly happy to entertain
something else but important reason to
go with what missimo says and this is a
point about Dan's uh Martian
Anthropologist is that Dan suggested and
I'm sympathetic with this that uh
there's something that the Martian
Anthropologist would want to um
attribute to us but actually if you look
at uh classical Indian philosophy
whether it be Hindu Jane Buddhist or CL
IAL Chinese philosophy there is no
concept of Free Will as there not is
none in ancient Greek philosophy there's
a distinction between voluntary and
involuntary behavior and that seems much
more congenial to evolutionary
scientists because then it will be and
this is congenial usually I think Dan
will find this friendly and what Terry
said about his bird and his dog I mean
there's some and and what Steve was
saying about say breathing respiration
things that are done by the autonomic
nervous system and things that are done
in other other ways by humans some are
happenings and some are actions some are
voluntary and some are involuntary it's
I I I think if one looks at the history
of the concept of Free Will in the west
it is so tied in with the theology it's
invented at a time when there's
faculties that when the mind is being
considered as divided into certain
faculties and in addition and I think
this is where Jerry's right radical a
Libertarian autonomy is considered the
only is necessary for God not to be a
prick for for either rewarding or
punishing you for all eternity it's just
so I I do think that there's a there's a
there's a clearly a strong strain in our
tradition of this particular concept of
free will I think I think it's such a
hybrid concept I do think that there's a
way out and other cultures haven't
needed it they do the same work they
reward and punish and they think about
people as culpable or non-culpable for
their actions but it does clearly and I
think this is on Dan side this part is
that part of a one criteria is
that uh things that I do are usually
preceded by conscious Pro their
approximate cause it looks like now um
is some kind of conscious
volition uh and um and sometimes
reasoning and sometimes thinking about
the kind of person I want to be
something that something that hasn't
been
mentioned and and this does connect of
course with what we discussed yesterday
uh once one uh takes masimo's point on
board right and recognizes that no when
we when the defender of Free Will should
not be defending this magical uh instant
uh Timeless little event uh you know the
the decisions are real processes done
over Real Time by brains that can take
minutes or days or hours or years uh
once we recognize that then the only it
seems to me the only reason any reason
to be skeptical of whether that kind of
free will exists is going to be a reason
to be skep iCal about any kind of
causation except uh the micro bangings
that uh that analytic metaphysicians
ideas of fundamental physics traffic in
right I mean it's so so you're into the
whole among analytic for the
non-philosophers here among analytic
metaphysicians there's a common view
that baseballs can't break Windows right
because after all most of the baseball
didn't come into contact with the window
right only some molecules of the
baseball came into contact with some
molecules of the window right a baseball
is a big macroscopic object it can't do
anything right only only the sort of
smallest components of the baseball can
do things unfair to analytic
metaphysics but it's
crazy but this is crazy and and
similarly I mean so so a little bit more
seriously than the baseballs and windows
stuff this well-known philosopher jaguan
Kim argues there's no mental causation
at all right thought doesn't no he does
not argue that Don that's completely
unfair he argues that mental causation
is physical causation yeah well he
become he winds up as un limited of his
di yes he does yes he does he's got the
problem of overdetermination we don't
want to go there the point is the point
is I don't
see the central point is right it seems
to be the only reason to be doubtful of
free will once we take mimo point on
board is going to be a reason to be
doubtful of all macro level causation or
actually when you just say of if you
take the micro banging around view then
you would just say something like
conscious mental causation is epip
phenomenal would that be the challenging
view what's going
to that's a view that I I think it's
exactly I mean if there were people who
said that baseballs don't break Windows
because most of the molecules don't hit
the window they would be making exactly
the mistake of using molecule talk in a
discussion about baseballs and and so I
will I will retract my previous opining
that there's no such thing as causality
in the world for exactly that reason um
I think time is a different thing so I
got I got uh excited by that but
causality I think you know you can make
a case that exists in the macroscopic
world subject to the second law and and
the and so forth and it disappears the
level of of shinger equation or whatever
but it's real in the same exact sense
that baseball is real as a sport and
Free Will is real as a way of thinking I
wonder why people aren't willing to do
it m says and I suggest get rid of the
term I be very open to that well let me
let me talk about that because because
all right I'm gonna I'm going to say all
right I I I could imagine getting rid of
it and I would replace it with something
like morally competent
volition and it's not going to win any
popularity contest exactly
volunt but but every every term in that
is important it's not just competent
volition it's competent enough to be
held
responsible and it's not absence of
causation it's that my volitions are
caused to advert to the sort of points
that Stephen was making my volitions are
caused for the most part not not all of
them but the ones that matter the ones
that are morally relevant by my uh
evaluation of
reasons that I have obtained by
processes of of inquiry and and I I am a
a responsible gatherer of information
and I'm a
responsible uh protector of myself from
manipulating agents I am on the constant
uh uh it's not a big deal I don't want
to be manipulated by other agents so
Charles Whitman for example and it could
be possible that he killed 16 people
because he had a brain tumor that made
him aggression
yeah okay so he is he you would not hold
him responsible for what he did because
he's he's I mean he had no yeah and I
would say that in the case he he has to
be kept he has
to look lots of people are dangerous
lots of people are no I would I don't
know that I don't agree that I wouldn't
hold him responsible I don't know
exactly what the effect of the brain
tumor is if the brain tumor makes him
think that he's not really killing
anyone then I wouldn't hold him
responsible but if the brain tumor gives
a strong desire to kill people then I
hold him responsible he can't overcome
well uh what if you could remove the
brain tumor what what if you could
remove the brain tumor would you still
be holding responsible
afterward yeah I mean then need's a
different person I don't know that's the
question is could it's all the could
piece right that's where it's all hiding
I think that we have a better theory of
Charles Whitman then a freely operating
thing right you know the theory that
he'll go kill people is better than one
that he's making rational decisions Bas
colleag Senator Armstrong has a a
detailed case of someone who was a
repeated sex offender and who was
diagnosed as having a a tumor that was
impressing a certain part of the brain
when it was removed he ceased entirely
to behave in these inappropriate way
towards his daughter uh he was
subsequently released from jail the
tumor regrew back and as it grew back
his Behavior returned to its previously
indictable uh pattern and again on the
removal of the tumor his behavior
returned to
normal so now what what what does one
make of this from the perspective of
retributive punishment well I'm puzzled
by the question uh that Sean asked which
you're also asking um if the tumor is
out uh he's
is he the same person that did he
himself actually had a first person
account of the entire train of events
which made it clear that from the first
person he thought of himself as
numerically identical over the repeated
interventions the criminality the trials
and the ultimate cure did he say why he
did the foul Deeds when he had had
overwhelming desire to do these deeds
and of course he knew nothing about his
his brain tumor initially and the
subsequent overwhelming desires Came
Upon him in ways that did not reveal
that they were caused by the recurrence
of the brain tumor but which his
Physicians were able to diagnose but you
see that's key I think when the question
of the responsibility of this man comes
up the question is whether he had
evidence for the recurrence was there a
time when he should have known that that
disabled and then we can say he's
responsible for not having taken the
steps the second time I just want to
follow so the the clearest way for me to
accept Free Will I think is one I got
from Sean and I want to do the argument
quickly so there there may be apparent
properties of a social theory or moral
theory who that are in contradiction to
the apparent properties of an underlying
Theory and so
they so so there there are these
properties and so in the examples the
second law so the base properties are
time invariance the emerging properties
are time are time in time symmetric as
symmetry thank you so so that that makes
it possible to believe in free will but
just because it's possible to have
theories up here that have totally
unfound physical prop doesn't mean we
should that's right and then the should
comes from Dan denn saying I don't want
to parody you but I I'm forced to um
just that the the reason we should
attribute these magical properties not
magical they're not magical they are
sorry uh the reason we should OB so no
emergence has been demonstrated no
derivation has been done no more magical
than the second law thermodynamic no no
no no it is magical because we're just
saying there it is not logically
impossible the derivation could happen
but we haven't done a der but does have
a theory of Consciousness right and the
theory of Consciousness Dan's Theory Of
Consciousness is supposed to among other
things would to tell us what this this
volition is like you also the fact that
we have experience Evolution having
having people have experiences of all
sorts of things that we don't believe
are true yeah but that's not ground for
dismissing experience across the no but
it's it's also not ground for believing
I don't I mean I want to be careful here
but so I can believe so I can believe in
Spirits at the high level I just say
they're emerging properties and they
they're in contradiction to underlying
properties but we don't want to just say
anything goes at this upper level no no
but that's the point they are in actual
contradiction to the underlying laws in
the way that violations of conservation
of energy would be not apparent
contradiction caused by the fact that
the domain of applicability is small
enough how can we what's the principle
by which we distinguish between apparent
and actual contradiction well I think
you know if if if you believe that
energy conservation the first law of
thermodynamics for example which came
after the second law it did but we would
not want to lose it on the road from the
micro Theory to the macro theory if if
we truly had we know enough about the
macro Theory to say the second the first
law of thermodynamics should survive
that transition even if we couldn't do
the derivation step by step and likewise
you know I think we can rule out life
after death because we know enough about
the micro Theory to say you know there's
no place for the information about your
mental states to go once you die whereas
free will all I'm saying about Free Will
is it seems to me to be part of the best
microscopic Theory I have for describing
human beings if we want to replace the
idea with a better idea like either
vocabulary term like volition or even a
better description of human beings I'd
be all for that because I can't derive
it that's fine I do think it's important
not to leave this discussion thinking
that that the the sort of set will VI
coming from Dan
is uh the neurosci the neuroscientific
arguments against fail cuz they're
philosophically naive and and Free Will
is really important politically and
culturally therefore we should be
compatibilists right in there's this
other big piece in there Dan has a
theory of the conscious volutional human
being right and and and which is
designed among other things to be a a
sort of explanation sketch for how
Evolution produced it and how it
computes that how its brain produces its
mind um and how its brain in interaction
with the environment produces uh
meaningful self narratives and produces
selves of the kind that can be authors
of their own activity so all that
stuff's really quite important too right
if if we had no story like that we'd be
much more
worried yeah Jerry
um somebody wrote a paper recently
somebody wrote a book recently called my
brain made me do
it now you take a deep breath and think
about this what else would you want to
make you do it
but but more
seriously there are ways your brain
could make you do it and then there are
other ways your brain could make you do
it and the trick is which kind of way is
it the the intermediate theory that Dawn
is talking about is the one which takes
on that challenge and says if this is
how your brain makes you do it you're
responsible that you're a morally
competent individual those that's what
we all want to be true of ourselves and
guess what folks it's possible we can be
wired right well I gu if your brain made
you do it in some other way then you're
wired wrong and then you aren't
responsible well I don't think there's
different ways your brain makes you I
don't in I mean maybe this is radical
but substantively I don't think there's
any difference between somebody killing
somebody or being a petophile because
they have brain tumor or somebody
killing somebody because they were
beaten up as a kid which affected their
neurons in such a way that they had no
choice but to be angry and go out and
kill somebody and that allies seamlessly
through allev
and and also with also with the person
who uh who decides uh to commit a crime
and then commits a murder to cover the
crime when he just simply thought he
could get away with it you don't think
there's any difference with that brain
either I don't Jerry so so it's
interesting you put it that way because
and I I I hav encountered that often
this argument that for all effective
purposes there is no no substantive
distinction between somebody committing
murder because of the brain tumor and
something somebody committing murder
because you know you know you wanted
your cash or whatever it is right but
that to me right right of course there
there is a causal story to be told there
but again um it seems to me first two
two things first of all if you take
seriously the idea that the human brain
is a organ to make decisions then the
situations actually are different there
are different inputs into the brain
there are different circumstances the
brain elaborates that that information
differently and in one case there's more
constraints impos the tumor there is
more constraints imposed in that brain
the brain is malfunctioning and so one
of the things that I really am puzzled
Often by by that the brain tumor
argument is that the brain tumor is
clearly a case where I think most of us
would agree the brain is not working
properly it's it's wired up wrongly and
so that that case cannot possibly be
representative I think of a general the
general trauma then well so that's an
interesting one so I was just thinking
when you you mentioned that so the case
of childhood trauma and I'm making stuff
as I go in a moment but but surely some
neurobiologist could could back this up
that one might be intermediate that
might be a situation where the the
constraints imposed on your brain are
going to be less than the tumor but but
more than a normal person up normal
brain is I mean we all have causes for
what we do I mean my view is that there
responsibility but there is a curve
there is a there is a bell curve so your
tumor is over here and you know your
incredibly good education nurturing
environment everything is going out well
is over there and then there's the rest
of us
in I don't understand the distinction
between your word responsibility and
moral responsibility I mean uh because
responsibility can Remedy by simply
locking keeping because moral
responsibility engenders retribution
seems to me I mean I don't see what
someone you takes you're responsible you
go to jail yes why is that not
retribution I mean it's true that there
are other reasons for putting people in
jail which may not including deterrence
and so on but you are not talking about
deterrence you talking about
responsibility I don't see the
difference when somebody's responsible
it means that for example if that means
that they're they may be liable to do it
again if you could determine absolutely
that this crime was a onetime thing and
they never again you would by
responsibility you mean prevention that
you prevent the act from being two
reasons I see for punishment all right
before you say them Jerry I will play
the role of the coffee police I will let
Jerry say his two reasons and then may I
make one legal summary before that
please I'm not a very good policeman I
guess okay so Jerry can say his two
reasons and then you can summarize deter
and Rehabilitation that's it okay I I I
I think the the conversation on law let
me just comment on that I think it's
been really mudy so I want to have my
say on this if somebody commits a crime
you need to discuss whether or not
there's Menor a volition I like the
volition word better whether or not
there really is valtion or free will we
can't have Society without having that
construct so I think we got to have that
so you got to determine whether or not
there was Criminal Intent you could make
out you're making up cases that are very
much on the line I think it's pretty
irrelevant those are very unusual and
special cases and the idea of convicting
somebody is for several purposes in my
view one is deterrence you want to keep
people from committing a crime again
another is removing people from society
who in fact are are are non rehabilitat
I think the goal needs to be rehabilit
if you guys really want to punish people
and take their fingernails off cuz
you're mad at them I want to put that
aside I personally don't subscribe to
that I also think that this level of of
responsibility extends to 11year olds if
an 11-year-old commits a crime you also
need to determine these same things you
need to deter that behavior you may do
it differently you need to remove from
from society potentially and you try to
rehabilitate them um so and then by the
way if it turns out that they're not
uh they didn't have Criminal Intent but
they might kill again you have to lock
them up by reason of insanity which has
the same kinds of purposes say in fact
locking them up for for the because they
had volition and finally of course
there's negligence which has another set
of of potential so if you say well they
didn't mean it but they did something
bad because they were stupid there's
civil law that deals with that so I want
to kind of remove all these legal
questions which frankly I've heard a lot
of very muddy approaches to that's my
view on the legal side and all of that
is assuming that we are dealing as if
there were free will and I I'm not
convinced by any of you whether or not
there is I don't know about that I'm not
sure from listening to any of this you
can ever determine that but I think for
practical purposes going along with
sha I'm I'm a Shaun on this but those
are my uh those are my legal views could
could I just apologize I'm having to
leave um because I've got to get back
and I'm frightened of being of being
trapped so thank thank you all very much
and thank you to Nick I just want to
leave you with this four line poem by
Pete Hine nature it seems is the popular
name for milliards and milliards and
milliards of particles playing their
infinite game of Billiards and
billiards who wrote that Pete Hine oh
yes yes okay and uh and so Richard is
leaving I guess but everyone else raise
their hand if they want to be in the
dinner party 7:30 tonight 1 2